how long does it take you to make that
decision to do the Moodle I said no you
said that's the best thing the truth is
I done you know a Mission Impossible
movie a Star Trek I didn't wanna do
another sequel right I'm sick of you
know doing movies with numbers yeah but
I think sequels are so hard I mean
because there's such fan expectation
with sequels as a fan I was I'd rather
just go to the theater and watch the
movie right and then Cathy said can we
can we get together Cathy's the person
from Disney Cathy Kennedy who is one of
the great producers of all time and we
just started talking about what this
thing could be and it just poured out of
you as we were talking about I found
myself suddenly on fire about what did
you say in that meeting that would that
turn you on about Star Wars the idea
that Luke Skywalker Han Solo Princess
Leia this is 40 years ago so for someone
who's 19 years old this is like their
myths who knows what they know about
them you know people wouldn't even know
maybe who some of these characters are
and the thing that got me that grabbed
me was that feeling of a new young
character and in the case of this
conversation it was a female character
didn't know anything about her but in
the conversation that question of this
young woman asking who is Luke Skywalker
I don't know why but it made me feel
like that's so cool that idea that there
will be a discovery these will be you
know essentially kids who didn't see
Star Wars themselves in this movie who
would be in this universe but that turns
you on yes the idea of sort of
discovering rediscovering this world
that had been created